- How do you balance it?
'Cause it's hard, I get it.
Balancing a career, family, everything going on.
How do you do that?
- Well, fame is tricky.
And fame can be a very tricky thing, as you know.
As you guys can imagine, and we've experienced.
And it could be very intoxicating to people.
And I also feel with fame,
I felt early that it was really important
to keep perspective and to understand that really fame
is like a microscope.
And it magnifies who you are as a human being
and what you have in your DNA
and your soul. - True colors.
- True colors, your true colors, sure.
And I think what's helped me and certainly my family
is just remembering where I've come from
and keeping the hard times
that I've went through in the past.
Keep them at the forefront of my mind.
Help lead and guide me.
That way, if we're fortunate enough
to have any bit of success, whatever it is come our way,
you take it with a grain of salt.
You're super grateful that it happens, but--
- But it's not everything.
- It's not everything, no, not at all.
And just like that things can change.
So be super grateful.
I try and live in gratitude every day,
and laugh things off. - [Kelly] Yeah, I actually
have a gratitude journal. - You do?
- Yes, 'cause somebody told me.
'Cause I try and live like that
and my biggest fear in this industry,
I've never said this in an interview anywhere.
But I don't know why I'm saying it now.
(laughing)
- Talk to me. - You should be a host.
(laughing) (audience laughing)
No, my biggest fear is becoming those people you meet
that are so unhappy in this industry.
And I'm like, "What went wrong?
"Wait, you used to be really lovely.
"I knew you way back when."
And it's like, what went wrong?
And that's the thing,
I think you just lose sight of it and you chase.
And you don't enjoy.
- Absolutely, and I always think.
I get asked this question often,
and I'm sure you do, too.
"Don't you miss the anonymity of just being able
"to go the mall, or just being able to go out?"
'Cause that just doesn't happen anymore for me,
and I say. - Just for me.
This looks a lot different in real life, Dwayne.
(laughing) (audience laughing)
- I have put on bucket hats,
I have put on things. - [Kelly] I mean look at you.
- But I also remind myself,
"Well, what's the alternative?"
The alternative can be I go to how things were
when I had $7 in my pocket and that was it.
Or getting evicted. - [Kelly] Me, too.
- So I remember that.
- Running from the REPO man, I did it.
(laughing) (audience laughing)
I parked my car in my friend's apartment.
I was like, "Shoot, I don't know where it went.
"I don't know." (laughing)
"Somebody stole my car."